abdelkerim yacoub koungou me bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour nous éclairer sur la
situation au soudan ce matin sur rtl
france on le disait le général abdel
fattah al quran auteurs du coup d'état
du 25 octobre a donc conclu un accord
pour rétablir le premier ministre
abdallah and docks dans ses fonctions
qu'est ce qu'on sait de d2 sous de cet
accord aujourd'hui
pascale
breuil a eu tout ce qu'il voulait
aujourd'hui le plus grand damne de cet
accord
ce n'est pas le plus de données et la
société civile ou plutôt les militaires
et elle dure et la résine aussi parce
qu'on a vu pendant les négociations les
tractations le retour des certains
leaders dans le dancehall et nous avons
très bien vu qu'aujourd'hui en hardox le
tout avec un concert à la plein pouvoir
puisqu'il a réussi à écarter tous les
civils a sauté civils dont il ne voulait
pas il a remplacé par deux civils et
présentant des gens et non de mouvement
grâce aux civils nous avons vu très bien
qu'aujourd'hui il a réussi à diviser la
société civile en essayant de donner
plus tôt
le mettre la musique à son corps mais ça
le soutien lassé des civils majoritaire
aujourd'hui comme vous avez dit tout à
l'heure dans votre reportage
finalement aujourd'hui un dock c'est le
tout renforcé et soutenu par une partie
de la communauté internationale qui l'a
soutenue de villes comme l'egypte la
russie les émirats arabes unis l'arabie
saoudite et de l'autre côté il a un péno
ministre aeby est coupée de sa base donc
il peut aussi imposer certaines
décisions finalement le syogoc c'est le
trou c'est un pouvoir en quelque sorte
comme est né à cette transition quand il
a sauvé coup on souvient le la semaine
dernière c'est le secrétaire d'état
américain anthony blinken qui était en
visite sur le continent africain il a
parlé de la situation au soudan et il a
dit que bien les états unis
reconnaîtraient le soudan s'il y avait
le retour des civils est ce que les
conditions sont réunies aujourd'hui pour
que les etats unis reconnaissent à nous
les autorités soudanaises
juste en a les etats-unis ont demandé le
retour de signer ici
aux etats unis avant lui ce que vous
voulez mais seulement ses activités de
toute sa substance en dehors sans la
société civile qui le portent le
changement et la liberté qui aujourd'hui
sont en train de manifester dans la rue
sont en train de le contester ce n'est
qu'un symbole finalement mais
cela pour sauver la page parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont plus que jamais
besoin des albums et du soudan dans la
gestion de la crise en ethiopie donc
aujourd'hui la personne plus c'est la
gloire ni le soudan mais la pression est
plutôt du côté de la crise et y
reviennent ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
le verre à moitié vide pour les
européens et les américains mais ils
accepteront parce qu'ils ont besoin d
impliquer la cuisse et qui vient alors
le premier le ministre abdallah diop qui
va donc devoir former un gouvernement
n'imaginent il va
s'entourer de personnalités civiles
c'est lui qui va aller choisir où c'est
le général abdel fattah le bourg ain
il va le choisir mais étant donné
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun
membre de la cit et steve hill au sein
des concessionnaires ça veut dire que le
cboe randonnée à son dernier mot hamdane
choisi et elle brode invalide donc s'il
ne
donne rien faire donc aujourd'hui on
donne mais qui a finalement
une validation de l'accord entre les
états unis la communauté internationale
qui soutient le bourrin et albran
finalement non final c'est le trouve une
tradition médicalisé est aujourd'hui la
pyrite et nos pneus n'est pas aussi le
dessin des élections tout de suite
maintenant elle le trouve finalement
sous le commandement à te dire non
alors en tout cas un accord qui suscite
la colère des manifestants des anti
putschistes est-ce qu'ils sont nombreux
au soudan où part ils représentent une
majorité de la population ou c'est une
minorité active
non absolument
à cette minorité on essaie de les
minimiser on essaie de les invisibilité
on essaie d affaiblir s'il veut faire
invisible est minoritaire mais pourquoi
on s'acharne à les diviser on s'acharne
à les premières à balles réelles en
sachant à de les diviser aujourd'hui si
cette force civile n'est pas aussi
menaçante et puissante comme donc ne va
pas se permettre même de prendre
si aujourd'hui
c'est aussi une façon de pouvoir
affaiblir ses éternels adversaires qui
sont la cité civile dans le partage de
pouvoir au début de la transition était
équilibré
aujourd'hui on sait le tout dans un
partage des pouvoirs déséquilibrée en
faveur des militaires avec un penny
ministre faible est coupée de sa base
donc ça continuera
ses conseillers avec ses anciens
camarades la société civile est bien la
tradition c'est la toujours
alors justement à quoi peut-on
s'attendre dans les jours dans les mois
qui viennent quant à cette transition
démocratique et moral des mots pardon
démocratique un qui a été voulue en 2019
si vous avez bien écouté au début entre
les deux déclarations des arbres et des
attaques on va le bien les deux nuances
un dock dit bien dit que cet accord
permet d'élever certains blocages et
elles meurent indiqué c'est ce que ne
peut plus blake donc maintenant on va
les mettre transition général
de blocage déblocage il faut saluer tous
les blocages et donc du coup finalement
on voit très bien qu'il ne sent pas la
même longueur d'onde et qu'il fallait
s'attendre à des tensions maintenant ça
dépend aussi de l'évolution de la crise
à youtube et daily motion de la position
de la communauté internationale
qui est du côté sera diffusé en deux la
communauté internationale
et de notre côté on a la russie l'egypte
l'arabie saoudite les conditionnels
debron donc finalement est ce que la
communauté internationale va réussir à
s'entendre entre elles pour pouvoir
aider le peuple se donner à avancer et
de l'intérieur est ce qu'ils veulent
nations entament la société civile et
random afin de pouvoir récupérer ce
qu'ils ont perdu dans cette négociation
à qui les accueillent en leur défaveur
merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage
abdelkerim yacoub koundougou me merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france je le rappelle vous
êtes chercheur associé ips e et
directeur afrique isf